same thing with um have you seen did you
see the uh home
home title lock commercial yes oh i saw
one the other day
oh my god austin can you pull that up
please
i i kid you not i'm standing out front
of my house with the front door open i'm
smoking
and i hear that's all tv's running and i
hear i'm like that sounds like [ __ ]
matt cox i peek my head in the door and
it was like the last
couple seconds of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
security commercial and i saw matt on
there and then it clipped to some other
i said no [ __ ]
i tried
i think i was watching the basketball
game or something it was on a popular
channel
oh oh it's it's on cnn as well was it on
tnt there's a 30 minute i was watching
the basketball game
there's a 30 minute infomercial in the
mornings on saturdays and sundays that
they
luke like for like two hours
same thing over and over again but they
do
um so it's so funny because it's crazy
you know my mom
it was the first time i ever saw it did
you know the first time i saw it was
with my mom
i'm eating i'm eating lunch with my mom
yeah this is what i mean breakfast with
my mom look at this
do you have this on the screen all right
well wait a minute you got
first they got that wrong they must have
pulled that right off look at that mug
yeah that's a bad one keep going not
great
wait con man reveals the truth about
home title fraud the fbi calls title
whoa god damn that's loud
can we make it bigger is this it
this must be it yeah press play newt
gingrich
newt gingrich i've always believed that
the real
america is the home it's a sacred place
so funny and it's the foundation
of your retirement that's why i want you
to know the truth
about home title theft the fbi calls
home title theft
one of the fastest growing white collar
cyber crimes in america
why here's why me too
look at that scoundrel look at that
beautiful beautiful con man
against the united states with the
beautiful hairline social security
look at the old picture glorious
hairline
how many properties did i falsely buy or
acquire in multiple names and borrow
against i mean
around 150. first of all thank you for
being honest and sharing with us how did
you get into taking your houses
actually owned a mortgage company it
slowly developed and you
just learned the particular skill set
that it required
and were you surprised how easy it was
it's extremely easy
oh my god this is great and why is that
in order for me to take your house it's
newt gingrich public records
create a document why is he interviewing
you
they had um transfer to someone else
that i'm in control of and then i can
borrow against the house
they always have a big time guy who's
who's their their main
spokesperson okay you find out that your
house has been sold
are they rudy giuliani for a couple
years really yeah they had
glenn back
if someone steals your home's title you
have to listen
they don't even use like they did like
an hour long
maybe maybe a two-hour conversation with
me not between me and newt gingrich but
me and
like the producers it was brutal
i mean i was in real psychopath form
i was just over the top like they're
like so
do you do you feel so do you feel bad
for these people no
i don't feel bad i don't feel anything i
mean i was just totally i don't know i
was in a bad mood i don't know what
happened i was just totally like
psychopaths jacked on coffee how much
how much coffee had you oh
three at least three vinci there's three
of these i walked in with one of them
you know i was
it was it was just total so you're a rip
roaring oh it was great it was great and
then when it was done
they were like you know we'll probably
use a little bit of that a little bit i
said no i said you say well it was a
little little harsh i said
bro i said use it i said make me sound
like a complete
scumbag scoundrel con man
psychopath i said i don't care i said
look i'm not going for the whole
oh i'm reformed i feel bad i said no i'm
going for the joker
i said so jokerize me i said i don't
care said you're not going to make me
feel
bad like oh i'm a psychopath you can't
make me feel bad i don't feel bad i said
so
do it run with it and they were like oh
you should have seen
yeah right you should have seen the look
on their face
they were like and i said do it
i said i got no problem i said listen
the people that the people that
know me and like me and care about me
they already know who i am
like and i'm not looking for any new
friends so if everybody else hates my
guts
that's fine whatever nobody's going to
hunt me down and kill me i'm good
so my point is you know i so i told them
that
they still then they did the commercial
and so the guy called me the producer
and i was like bro he's like did you see
it i was like
man you didn't really he's like i know
you know someone was really harsh and i
was like it's fine i said are you
concerned that
he's like you know we didn't want to
make you look too bad because you're
kind of like a spokesperson
kind of like it you don't want you know
when i'm to sell some lifelock
yeah we're trying we don't scare people
i was like oh man so anyway look the
commercials are doing so well they
called me back
they want me to come back and do another
commercial
and they're supposed they're supposed to
be sending me um a right now
well this was actually about a week ago
we talked about i think it might have
been two weeks ago
they said they were gonna have a meeting
he goes and we're trying to figure out
how to use you
for like the next three years on like an
exclusive deal nice
and i'm sitting there going they're like
so we're going to put something together
here we go again right i'm thinking
where do i sign
are you serious and i'm they're like i
mean if you they wanted me to call you
make sure you're okay with them
am i okay with it yeah yeah i'm good
i'm good let's do this absolutely run
with it wouldn't that be hilarious
that's amazing and that would be funny
people sending me text messages saying
bro i was just watching fox news just
watching cnn
i was just watching this and you
suddenly i turned around you were there
yeah i'm like yeah bro i talk about it
all the time you are like the biggest
success story of this podcast
like you are the for sure you are the
one person who came in here
nobody knew who the [ __ ] you were and
you literally
taken the ball and ran with it ran with
it i i mean i said
and this is the thing with all by the
way the guy you have created such
success out of coming from nothing
coming on this podcast
is it really for you it's literally me
like i'm not talking about the amount of
attention you got just
from as far as podcast views on my
channel right i'm talking about like
what you've turned it into
after that oh yeah let's listen i'm
going i'm going to
i'm okay so i think i'm supposed to go
to chicago in a couple weeks and be on
somebody's podcast
i i've been like all over you know i've
been to like ohio i've been to
california i've been to illinois i've
been to
puerto rico i've been to like i've been
all over the place doing podcasts
and getting doing like
like i told you about like when i went
to puerto rico and they gave me like
1800 bucks to like fly into puerto rico
and have a lunch with these guys with a
couple of [ __ ] billionaires on puerto
rico they just want to hear my story
and then i leave um so you were
basically just like entertainment for
the night
a couple billionaires and i was telling
the guy i was like so i mean what why
and they're like you know we usually
have somebody come and we i saw your
stuff and i said to the other
guys they love your stuff and we just
like you to come just have lunch i'm
like
i can't do that for free yeah no offense
but i gotta get paid
do you imagine they fly matt to [ __ ]
epstein island just for the night they
came a million dollars
would you do it yeah hell yeah he'd
[ __ ] do it
um so clip that i want the thumbnail of
that to be matt's face
with epstein island and uh epstein's big
dome house in the background um so look
so
i'm going to amsterdam oh yeah yeah
they've watched the
i'm going to amsterdam for four or five
days the end of august
to be in a there's a six-part series
called the psychology of a of conor mann
and there's six part they got one guy
from asia
they've got a guy from germany a guy
from france a guy from the uk
um guy from someplace else oh like japan
or something
and they've got and guess who represents
the united states of america matthew cox
no [ __ ] way when i was zooming them
and they were like and i was like so
wait a second
so i go so you got a guy here i go so
are you saying that i'm representing the
united states for like the top
con man like that and they were you
could see they they get scared
like they're like they're looking like
um well um
and they were like i mean i would have
to say yes and if
i go yes yes i go let's do it and they
were just like
i said that's awesome that's awesome
they were like oh that is not the
response we typically get
um they're gonna fly me and they're
gonna do a battery of tests i said so
you're gonna try and figure out what
makes me
a con man they're like yes it's gonna be
a battery a test there's a psychiatrist
oh really that's interesting i can't
wait to see that
sign me up let's do it um and they've
watched all the stuff on concrete so
it's that
then i'm also going to like the um it's
the association of mortgage brokers
i'm going to that that's an alabama
association of march workers they're
flying me in to do
i'm flying in and
for one day i'm flying in oh [ __ ] sorry
flying in the morning 45 minutes tell my
story 15 minutes q a
jump back on the plane fly right back
out wow what's the flight out that flies
like a 13 hour flight
to alabama oh no i thought you're
talking about [ __ ] uh
you're talking about amsterdam amsterdam
is like 15 hours
yeah it probably is pretty bad um it
ain't like
it's worth the flight yeah i can i hope
it's not like spirit
hopefully it's not hopefully it's not a
[ __ ] six hour tournament like that
listen it's not like it's not like i've
never been in a small
uncomfortable you know position for 15
hours at a time or 12. like you put me
in a
small box with my hands cuffed like this
and i'd be like i could eat a sandwich
doing that go to the bathroom
i can open up a little juice box i can
do everything with my hands like this
true
file on 9.95